friends and relatives are mourning the
five people who died on Border
submersible taking tourists to the wreck
of the Titanic an implosion is being
blamed for the loss of the sub as it
descended into the depths of the
Atlantic the U.S Coast Guard says an
underwater robot discovered debris on
Thursday after the submersible was last
seen on Sunday questions are now being
raised about safety regulations in the
field and why this submersible have not
sought certification
there are regulations in place but as
you can imagine uh there aren't that
many Subs that go that deep and so the
regulations are pretty sparse and many
of them are Antiquated or they're
designed for specific instances so
um so it's it's uh kind of tricky to
navigate those those regulatory schemes
well James Cameron director the
Hollywood Blockbuster Titanic and has
completed 33 Dives to the Shipwreck he
says this trip should never have been
made
Ocean Gate shouldn't have been doing
what it was doing I think that's pretty
clear I wish I had been more vocal about
that but I think I was unaware that they
weren't certified
uh because I wasn't really studying it I
wasn't really interested Stockton Rush
asked me if I wanted to go out there and
dive this season you know I wasn't
interested search search four days of
search they're searching everywhere
they're they were running around with
their hair on fire the sub was right
where it was it was literally on the sea
floor below its last known position
which is the first place you look in a
search is the last known position you
don't go running around all over the
landscape with planes and Trains and
Automobiles searching right it was right
where it was when it imploded and I knew
that's where they were going to find it
they were on descent
they were at 3 500 feet
they lost comms
and tracking the last one being the
critical one
because the the transponder that's used
to track a sub
during descent and on the bottom is a
fully autonomous system
it's in its own pressure housing
and it has its own battery power
so for them to lose comms and tracking
at the same time sub was gone
well starting with this Gabriel Elizondo
is in Boston where the U.S Coast Guard
was helping with the search and Gabriel
already there's been a lot of finger
pointing over whether the sub it should
have launched in the first place
yeah that's right and the Coast Guard
was asked about that and they said that
they're going to be looking into this in
the coming days weeks and months they
said uh we have some of the same
questions that others have about the
safety standards of this submersible
that was really an experimental
submersible it wasn't up to
military-grade standards by any stretch
of the imagination far from it quite
frankly but there's certainly some
complications as well because where this
Titanic is at and where the Titan was
going to explore that's international
waters there so who sort of would
regulate the safety standards in
international waters is something that
governments quite frankly are going to
have to start talking to each other
about and you know there's some
questions about well you know if
Millionaires and billionaires want to
take these extreme risks to explore
either outer space or the depths of the
ocean what does it matter well as we saw
from this incident what matters is when
something goes wrong of course it's up
to governments in this case England the
U.S France and Canada to Marshal all
these resources that are costing tens of
millions if not hundreds of millions in
the five-day search so certainly a lot
of questions but it's really coming down
now to safety standards and a lot of the
people in the exploration Community The
Wider Community are now looking at each
other saying do are there do there need
to be higher safety standards and also
how are those safety standards
implemented and as we saw it was an
extensive search I mean do we have any
more details about how the debris was
found
hello
well It ultimately came down to one
thing and in the end and that was this
ROV or remotely operated vehicle it's
basically a a robot uh that has a
capability to go to these depths and
then feedback live video to cruise on on
the surface on a ship on the surface
again we've said this over and over but
it can't be repeated enough the depths
of where this occurred are so deep that
very few submarines can even get there
there's only a handful of them uh on the
planet that have the capability these
robots to get to these depths and so by
the time that they were able to mobilize
these and get there that's ultimately
what proved uh uh decisive is is this
getting there to see able to get to
those depths to feedback video to see
the debris and that's ultimately uh what
was the key here of course they used
airplanes ships on the surface even
sonar buoys to pick up sounds but bottom
line is what this tragedy taught is that
at these extreme depths you have to have
something that can get there to actually
see what is on the sea floor at these
depths and ultimately it was one of
these rov's remotely operated vehicles
that was the key to finding the debris
Gabriel thanks very much for that update